il est vrai qu'en acheter tes couilles
oui sans doute assez temps voilà le
bonheur de randy c'est le gagnant du
concours de dessin organisé par le foyer
départemental de l'enfance nord-est et
ce jour là nous sommes avec neuf
personnels éducatifs de maîtresse de
maison de surveillants de nuit
l'équipe passerelle veille sur ses
enfants 365 jours par an dans le
confinement mais il a fallu qu'on
réinvente notre façon d'intervenir
auprès des enfants
vu que l'on pouvait pas aller recevoir
un entretien individuel donc on a
proposé diverses activités et en 3 tri-
il ya eu le volcan qui a eu pendant le
confinement à un moment donné le volcan
répéter ou pas on s'est dit qu'on allait
faire un concours de dessins sur cette
thématique
ce n'est pas pour rien aussi qu'on a
choisi le thème du volcan qui pète parce
qu'il s'agissait aussi pour nous de
trouver des outils de régulation
émotionnelle
pendant cette période où il ya beaucoup
d'agitation et c'est donc on s'était dit
que ça allait bien avec ce qui pouvait
être un peu la problématique des enfants
à ce moment-là vous remercier pour
effectivement à laval
c'est ce confinement c'était exigeant
c'est difficile et le comportement des
enfants de sur la structure a été
remarquable alors roujan de tambours le
gall y aurait un regard bienveillant sur
des enfants accompagnés par le
département dans le nord-est il existe
cinq structures de ce type pour 56
places et dans toute l'île 492 enfants
sont accueillis en établissements et
1916 en famille d'accueil pendant le coc
vide
le département a soutenu l'encadrement
de ses enfants par des aides matérielles
et financières des unités qui doivent
offrir un cadre d'épanouissement aux
enfants il était tout le temps tout le
temps pourtant que payer bon il ya des
moments où les enfants chercher leurs
familles skate à fait normal
il y avait peu de visites tout mais on a
pu traverser ce moment
en particulier j'ai vu mon équipe
différemment aussi ils étaient tous là
donc tous les jours il venait travailler
il venait avec entrain et là je me suis
dit dans ces moments difficiles
effectivement les gens sont différents
je dirai pas ce que je risque de
regretter ce moment là goûter et télé le
bonheur pour ces enfants qui poursuivent
leur après midi et c'est à sainte
suzanne au siège administratif du foyer
départemental nord-est que tous les
dessins sont regroupés et les enfants
cette capacité à s'exprimer autrement
que par les mots et là c'était ça ça en
a été une belle illustration
on a prévu de laisser les dessins tout
le mois de juin pour que
les personnes qui viennent au foyer
puisse en profiter et aussi pour les
enfants qu'ils souhaitaient de servir
d'affichage au sein des structures qui
ont relevé au camp ou pour les enfants à
bien sûr on ira voir le voile comme avec
les enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]